until a few months ago we had a problem
of rising inflation expectations among
the Swedish public and decision-makers
in in the business community we're
preparing for higher inflation wage
negotiations were preparing for higher
inflation and the economy was perhaps
set for a higher level of inflation so
the central bank reacted by raising
interest rates to demonstrate to the
economic agents in the in the country
that this was not to be tolerated but
what has happened now is that
international prices have come down the
oil price is down a hundred dollars in a
few months and the raw material prices
food prices are on the way down it's a
totally different situation the impulses
that produce inflationary expectations
in my country are no longer there and
the the board of directors in the
central bank took notice of this said
now the threat of inflation is gone the
economy is in a very sharp fall and the
reasons they're now possibilities of
very very low inflation so there's no
need to have a higher interest rate
anymore so they made in totally
different assessment and that has after
having cut interest rates by another 100
basis points about a month ago another
175 today was was a welcome and I think
a well motivated